the main takeaway from this new poll 69%
of Canadians feel prime minister Justin
Trudeau should resign in 2024 ipsos took
a slightly different approach and asked
people to share their opinions as to why
they feel that way in their own words
and the reasoning broke down into two
camps 70% of Canadians saying that a
prime minister should go is really high
but it's a mix of things it's not just I
don't like this person or I don't like
what he's done there's other people who
are kind of uh thinking that you know
any change is a good change and then
there's another group of people who are
saying in order to position the liberal
party for the next election because I
can't vote for pul Ev and I can't vote
for singing I need another option on the
liberal bench as high as that 69% number
may be ipsos also found that almost as
many people don't expect Trudeau to go
anywhere 63% of respondents think it's
not likely that he will resign ahead of
the next election maybe that's because
he's been so consistent saying over and
over again he planned to stay on gearing
up to go head-to-head with conservative
leader Pierre PV when the time comes
historically Prime Ministers are often
pushed out rather than leaving on their
own and with no obvious air apparent
getting people excited political experts
say a liberal leadership race between
now and the next election poses a risk
for the party so much of its identity is
wrapped up in the Trudeau brand even if
that brand has lost some of its shine
during the government's 8-year run the
leadership race at this point would
divide the party would expose divisions
that are already there would create
question marks around what the party
stands for even more than there is now
there are now and I think the
conservatives would do what they do
really well which is jump out and Define
the person right away before they get a
chance to do it themselves if Trudeau
stays on a different danger with these
numbers are the people who choose to sit
out the next election they may not want
Trudeau to be prime minister again but
they're not prepared to vote
conservative or NDP and experts say that
can cause not just low voter turnout but
volatility in the electoral system and
for funding critical for the campaign
Abigail ban global news auta